Hurricane Florence is projected to be
the most powerful storm ever day at
North Carolina as the massive category 4
hurricane takes an ominous path towards
the southeast coast hurricane watches
have just gone up in the Carolinas with
maximum sustained winds of 140 miles an
hour
Florence is expected to get even
stronger today South Carolina North
Carolina Virginia and Maryland are all
under a state of emergency and take a
look at how big Florence is in this NASA
photo from space it's big it's expected
to make a landfall on Friday
David beg no is near Myrtle Beach South
Carolina where a mandatory evacuation
goes into effect later today David good
morning to you Gail good morning it is
go time right now in South Carolina in
Charleston they are setting up cones and
getting ready to turn around traffic
starts at 12 noon so we're in Myrtle
Beach that's the sign heading toward the
coast here's what happens let's go to
the drone shot where as the drone is
flying you see the traffic coming toward
our drone that will be reversed everyone
starting at 12 noon will be going one
way West people are being told to
evacuate more than 150 miles as
evacuations are also happening today in
North Carolina and Virginia there's
nothing about a house for staying in and
risking your lives in Oak Island North
Carolina the imminent threat from
hurricane Florence is forcing most
people to board up their homes and leave
town over the years I have seen the
damage that these storms can do so I
don't really want to take no chances no
I'm not gonna leave as always some
people living along the coast are
planning to ride out the hurricane
everything I own is here I have to be
here in Portsmouth Virginia the Coast
Guard issued a stern warning get out or
we might not be able to save you
even now
store shelves across Virginia North
Carolina and South Carolina are empty as
people flood the stores to buy
essentials in Wilmington North Carolina
there are lines to get gas propane and
even water inside though they've run out
of water as people tell us whether
they're staying or evacuating you know
it's a category 4 now yeah I just
curious hurricanes staying or leaving
all right
North Carolina's governor Roy Cooper has
activated 200 National Guard troops as
his state prepares for potentially
catastrophic flooding when weather
forecasters tell us life threatening we
know that it is serious so we asked the
North Carolina governor's office why
that governor hasn't ordered a coastal
evacuation like South Carolina they told
us David look it's up to the local
leaders in North Carolina to evacuate
however the governor reserves the right
to get involved so far he has not Norah
as for here in South Carolina I just
asked the trooper
what happens if people don't evacuate at
noon and he said listen we're not going
to pull them out of their houses if you
decide to stay it's your choice
you got a hunker down and ride it out
that is dangerous all right David thank
you